-Our first guest tonight is an Emmy-, Golden Globe-,
and Tony-winning actor you know from the show "Taxi"
and films like "Ordinary People,"
"Independence Day," and "Uncut Gems."
He received an Oscar nomination
for Best Supporting Actor for his work
in "The Fabelmans," which is in theaters and on demand now.
Let's take a look.
-Family, we love with art.
We meshuga for art.
You think I wanted to leave my sisters, my mama, and my papa
and go stick my stupid head in the mouth of lions?
-P-Putting your head in a lion's mouth is art?
-[ Laughs ] No.
Sticking your head in the mouth of lions was balls.
Making sure the lion don't eat my head, that is art.
-Please welcome to the show Judd Hirsch, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome, Judd. I'm so happy to have you.
-Ah, thanks. Very nice people.
I can't see them, but they're very nice people.
-They sound nice.
-It's not just a bunch of heads you stuck out there on sticks.
That's people. -Those are real people.
-Yeah. -Now, uh --
-Lunch would not be a bad idea.
-What's that? -Me and them.
A nice little lunch.
-You want to go out to lunch with the audience, now?
-Why not? -Alright. There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I don't drink. -Okay.
Now, Judd --
-That limits everything. -Right.
Now, before you offer to take everybody here out to lunch,
I bet there's not a single Oscar voter here.
I hope you're not trying to pander to the --
-Nah. Yeah, yeah. That would be nice, wouldn't it?
-Yeah. Now, this is -- -Yeah.
Are you sure about that?
-I'm not positive. I'm not positive about that.
-Oh, okay. -This is so exciting.
-No Academy members... -You might be -- If you win,
you'll be the oldest Oscar winner of all time.
Congratulations on the very possibility.
-You had to tell 'em that.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, wait a minute.
-I wouldn't believe it. You look fantastic.
-I beat Henry Fonda
for the longest time between nominations.
-Wow. -Right?
His was like 44 years and something.
And mine was like 42 years and something
or something like that, anyway. -Yeah.
-Or maybe that was the Golden Globes.
I don't know. But I beat him. -There you go.
He's not walking around bragging about it right now
for a lot of reasons.
[ Laughter ]
-Where the hell were they
all those 42 years, for Christ's sake?
-It has been a 42-year break.
You were nominated for "Ordinary People,"
a fantastic film. -Yeah.
-You were nominated against your co-star, Timothy Hutton,
which is surprising to me, because --
-Oh, that's a terrible story.
I mean, really, I was -- I mean, how --
Imagine a guy gets nominated for an Academy Award
and hopes he doesn't win.
Because we were in the same category
and he's the star of the show. -He was.
-They stuck him in the same category.
And -- And I thought -- I went to the ceremony
and can only think of, "Oh, God, if I win this,
it's going to be terrible, terrible, terrible.
What am I going to do? Am I going to say,
'Tim, I'm telling you, you deserved it.
Here. There. You deserved it.'"
And I would probably go into -- I would tell the press.
-Yeah. -"Sorry. "Thank you." You know?
But luckily, it happened the other way around, you know?
I mean, you never saw somebody
who was so relieved at not winning.
-So Timothy did win. -Yeah, he won.
-Your co-star won. Did he offer to give you the Oscar?
-No, no. No.
[ Laughter ]
-He was 19 years old.
-That's amazing. That's amazing. And an amazing film.
-Yeah, yeah. We had a really good, um --
Robert Redford directed the movie.
It was his first time, right? By the way, he won the Tony --
the Academy Award. -Yep.
-And, at one time, we go through the whole movie,
and it was a really, really tough movie because of the kid.
And he tells me the story. I'm his psychologist.
And in the last scene,
his girlfriend commits suicide or something like that.
And they put the track in a circle.
And we were going to come in and we were gonna --
Redford said, "You got to hug him."
This is before we started the movie.
I said, "They're gonna kill you."
Psychologists don't hug their client. They don't."
He said, "This one will."
'Cause he had kids, and they never did it or something.
So he puts this track around us. And we start off.
And he comes in, and he's telling me the story.
And I'm telling him as a psychologist,
"Because. Because it wasn't you. Because you're okay.
And because he died and it wasn't your fault!"
And around and around and around.
And we finally -- And he says,
"I'm your friend. I'm your friend. Count on it."
Hmm. And we did it.
And Redford went, "Wow. Great. Great. Great."
About a month later,
I meet him on the street outside of Paramount.
He's gonna shoot the scene where the kids are in the boat.
I said, "Hey." He goes, "Hey."
I said, "How did it come out?"
He said, "I cut it."
[ Laughter ]
-Well, there you go. That's movie making for you.
-I was going use that shot for everything
On every talk show I could go on. You want to see --
-You should have brought it today.
-You want to see drama?!
You want to see how well a guy can shoot a shot?
-We should start -- We should start offering our guests here
to bring clips from 42 years ago.
-Yeah, yeah.
-So, "The Fabelmans." This is such a wonderful film.
And you really sort of show up in this movie
and you take it by storm.
You yourself have lived this incredibly fascinating life.
Coney Island, the Bronx, served in the Army,
were an engineer for a while,
and then found your way into acting.
-Yeah. -Are you surprised today
that this thing you started out so many years ago,
you're still...?
-I was surprised the first day I got a job.
You know, I mean, really, I was --
I was everything but.
I was a college guy.
I mean, I was gonna be an engineer.
I went through -- I got a degree in physics
from the City College of New York.
I then went back and became -- and for --
I went to another school for art.
I thought I was going to be Van Gogh.
I mean -- Is that his name? -Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Vincent Van Gogh?
[ Laughter ] Whoa!
One day out of my house, I can't remember something.
And I was gonna be a painter.
I was gonna fly jets off the aircraft carriers.
I signed up. And I went like...
"You schmuck. Don't do that! You will die!"
-So, I want to ask you about "Taxi."
Because this is one of the greatest sitcoms of all time,
and it's the first place I saw you.
And I remember in the opening titles of "Taxi"
your name came before the title of the show.
-Whoa! -Now, at the time,
as a kid watching it, and I knew I was watching reruns,
I assumed, "Oh, my God. Judd Hirsch must have been
a giant star for them to put his name before 'Taxi.'"
-I was not. No, I was not.
-So were you surprised that they put your name first?
-Yeah, I mean -- when they first -- Okay.
I was in, like, "Rhoda."
Remember that play -- that television situation?
I had two episodes.
And that was it. That was it.
I then said, well, now I'm going to get out of television
and I'm going to go to Europe and I'm going to take my kid
and I'm going to do anything but.
And then all of the sudden this thing comes up.
And my agent said, "They want to know if you want to do this."
I said, "What is it?" "'Taxi.'"
"Oh, is it about New York?" "Yeah, New York guy."
I said, "Well, uh, um... Alright. I'll read it."
-Could your agent read from your face
you weren't that excited about it?
-Nah. They're never with you.
"You want it? You want to do it? Okay.
What should I tell them?"
I said -- I said -- This is actual.
I said, "Make them an offer they can't accept."
[ Laughter ]
Don't do this if you're an actor.
Don't do this. Because they're liable not to.
So he says, "Okay, they accept it."
I said, "Why?
It's going to be at least three years, and I'm 40."
-Yeah. -You know?
Shh. I was 42. -They had no idea you'd be
getting Oscar nominations well into your 80s.
-No. -Yeah.
-I mean, if they did, the name would have been larger.
[ Light laughter ]
-Okay, okay, okay. So what's left?
They said, "Billing."
And I said, "Oh, well, just -- What do they usually do?"
"Taxi" starring Judd Hirsch, Danny DeVito, ba ba ba ba ba.
However. However. It doesn't make any difference to me.
Okay. Opening night, we go to the producer's house.
And the whole cast is there at a bar in his house.
And he's got a TV up there. And I'm standing way behind.
And we never saw the show.
And we hear -- [ Imitating "Taxi" theme song ]
The music. The cab. Across the bridge.
The word "Judd Hirsch."
[ Laughter ]
They changed the name of the show?!
"Taxi."
So I go, "Oh, my God."
When they talked about billing, I never dreamed.
There's no other show I've ever seen.
-Ever seen. How did the rest of the cast
feel that your name came before "Taxi"?
-I luckily never asked them. -Okay. Good.
That's good advice.
-To this day, I still don't know.
-Well, that's very good.
-If you ask them, they'll be very polite.
"Oh, yes, of course! He was the big star!
He deserved --" Bull [bleep].
If I was one of them, I wouldn't think that way.
-Well, what a delight to have you here.
Congratulations on your nomination. Well-deserved.
[ Cheers and applause ] -Judd Hirsch, everybody.
-Thank you.
-"The Fabelmans" is in theaters and on demand.
We'll be right back with Justice Smith.